Blumenkohl 4 Euro letzte hat der 360
gekostet
70 Cent 80 cm wie vor vier fünf Monaten
man muss an allen Ecken sparen gucken
dass man es irgendwie hinkriegt und ich
gucke ganz besorgt in Zukunft da kommt
noch einiges davon zu denke ich in
Deutschland gibt es wieder so viele arme
Menschen wie zuletzt bei der
Wiedervereinigung selbst der Wohlstand
der Mittelschicht ist aktuell in Gefahr
es wird nicht nur alles massiv teurer
auch das Ersparte sofern überhaupt
vorhanden verliert dramatisch an Wert in
dieser kontextfolge wollen wir uns
ansehen wie es dazu kommen konnte und
vor allem wollen wir wissen gibt es
einen Weg der Inflation zu entkommen
oder ist das hier alles nur der Anfang
herzlich Willkommen zu Kontext
wir wachen morgen ist auf und sagen
heute habe ich wieder Geld verloren und
dieses bittere Erwachen hat ein
eindeutigen Namen Inflation Inflation
heißt sich aufblasen und das bezieht
sich natürlich auf den Preis und
Teuerung bedeutet zugleich Wertverlust
also Geld dass wir verdienen oder dass
wir auf unseren Sparbüchern haben
verliert an Wert weil alles teurer wird
für Butter zum Beispiel zahlen wir
aktuell mehr als doppelt so viel wie im
Jahr 2015 Preissteigerungen haben im
Wesentlichen zwei mögliche Ursachen
entweder erhöhte Produktionskosten oder
die Nachfrage übersteigt das Angebot das
passiert beispielsweise wenn Putin den
Gashand zudreht bzw ganz allgemein wenn
mehr Geld im Umlauf ist als Güter auf
auf dem Markt sind wobei eine gewisse
Inflation von zwei Prozent sogar
gewünscht ist um das Wirtschaftswachstum
zu fördern denn wenn wir damit rechnen
das Dinge künftig teurer werden dann
kaufen wir sie lieber jetzt statt die
Ausgabe aufzuschieben inflationswerte
wie im Mai 2022 von 7,9 Prozent haben
damit aber nichts mehr zu tun und sie
provozieren fast zwangsläufig Reaktion
in Zeiten in denen die Preise dauerhaft
steigen müssen auch die Tariflöhne mit
dauerhafter Wirkung steigen das ist
keine Zeit für der tarifpolitische
Handbremse dann kann es eben sein dass
ich eine Lohn Preisspirale ergibt dass
sich die Inflation sozusagen dynamisiert
und dann auch geldpolitisch sehr
schweren Griff zu kriegen ist eine
solche Kettenreaktion wird an die
Verbraucher weitergegeben die dann zum
Ausgleich höhere Löhne fordern was
wiederum die Produkte teurer macht und
so weiter während einige Ökonomen
besorgt sind dass wir in eine solche
Spirale geraten halten es andere nur für
ein theoretisches Modell sie ließ sich
in Deutschland wenn überhaupt bisher nur
ein einziges mal beobachten die Streik
s die wir in den letzten Wochen erlebt
haben und erleben haben vor allem ihre
Ursachen in der beängstigenden und immer
zunehmenden inflationstendenz
aus der Ölkrise meine Damen und Herren
ist am Wochenende eine offene
Währungskrise geworden das Stichwort
lautet Ölpreisschock in den 70er Jahren
führten Preissteigerungen bei Energie-
vergleichbar mit unseren heutigen
Preissteigerungen und dem astronomischen
Anstieg der Energiepreise in der Folge
des russischen Überfalls auf die Ukraine
auch damals
1973 war der Auslöser für die Ölkrise
ein Krieg der JOM kippur-krieg den
Syrien und Ägypten gegen Israel führt
weite Teile Europas erlebten heute eine
der ruhigsten Sonntage seit Kriegsende
ebenso wie in der Bundesrepublik galt
auch in Dänemark den Niederlanden
Belgien Luxemburg und der Schweiz wegen
der Ölkrise generelles Fahrverbot ein
gedämmt werden konnte die Inflation
damals nicht zuletzt durch
Energiesparmaßnahmen das berühmte
Sonntagsfahrverbot mit Fahrradtouren und
Picknick auf den autob aber auch durch
die Zinspolitik der Deutschen Bundesbank
diese Bilder entstammen meine Beitrag
des Formats Fernsehen als Zeitgeschichte
zur Ölkrise den sie in der Mediathek
finden bevor wir zu möglichen
Lösungsansätzen kommen und der Frage ob
wir zum Beispiel aus der Ölkrise der
70er Jahre lernen können möchte ich
versuchen die wesentlichen Ursachen der
heutigen rekordinflation aufzufächern
wir hatten ja gehofft dass wir jetzt
langsam in die Erholung nach der
Pandemie eintreten könnten nun haben wir
diesen
grauenvollen Krieg in der Ukraine im
Dezember habe ich 90 Cent bezahlt für
ein Liter und jetzt 1,58 Ursache 1 der
russische Angriff auf die Ukraine in der
Folge stiegen nicht nur die
Energiepreise auch die plötzlich
verschlossene Kornkammer Europas treibt
die Preise in normalen Zeiten liefern
Russland und die Ukraine ein Drittel des
globalen weizenexports selbst für uns
schlicht zu wenig Getreide auf dem Markt
ein Phänomen des vertraut erscheint
gleiches Bild andere Krise es gibt keine
Nudeln es gibt kein Klopapier zu einer
Art Panik scheint mir auszubrechen damit
sind wir bei der zweiten
inflationsursache der corona-pandemie
geschlossene Häfen unterbrochene
Lieferketten und die nullcovit-politik
Chinas bremsten die Globalisierung
brachten sie zeitweilig zum Stillstand
während die nationale und internationale
Produktion von Konsumgütern stark
zurückging vermehrten sich Hamsterkäufe
die Folge
Toilettenpapier Mehl Hefe aber auch Holz
und andere Konsumgüter wurden knapp und
teuer wir reden hier von Materialpreisen
die dann zwischen 15 und 35 Prozent nach
oben gehen und wir einfach auch nicht
mehr absehen können also können wir das
Haus noch finanzieren ein Teil der
Preissteigerungen hat der Staat
zumindest versucht vorübergehend
aufzufangen wir helfen Menschen mit
geringem Einkommen auch durch die
Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer mit der Rück
zum üblichen Mehrwertsteuersatz am 1
Januar 2021 wurden Konsumgüter teurer
zugleich stieg mit dem Ende der
corona-maßnahmen die Kauflaune der
Menschen die dadurch erhöhte Geldmenge
aber traf auf nach wie vor niedrige
Lagerbestände die Folge die
Inflationsrate die seit 2005 konstant
zwischen 1 und 2% lag kletterte auf 3,1
Prozent ein Jahr später im Februar 2022
stieg sie bereits auf
5,3%. zu diesem Zeitpunkt der höchste
Wert seit der Einführung des Euro der
vielleicht wichtigste Grund für die
heutige Inflation aber lag lange im
Verborgenen wurde zumindest wenig
beachtet es ist die Zinspolitik der
Europäischen Zentralbank so eine rasche
Zinssenkung sei einmalig dies sei auch
seit Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs in
Europa bis zur Einführung des Euro noch
nicht da gewesen
die Europäische Zentralbank hat heute
beschlossen das Geld fast nichts mehr
kosten soll sie vergibt Kredite für die
sie nur noch ein Prozent Zinsen verlangt
der Leitzins also der Satz zu welchem
sich europäische Geschäftsbanken bei der
Europäischen Zentralbank Geld leihen
können ist ihr Hebel die Preise im
Euro-Raum stabil zu halten und diesen
Leitzins hat die EZB seit der
Finanzkrise 2008 kontinuierlich
eingesetzt als Instrument um die
Wirtschaft in Europa anzukurbeln aber es
ist ein klares Signal an die
Öffentlichkeit dass die EZB weiterhin
die Konjunkturlage sehr kritisch sieht
und alles Mögliche tun wird um die
Banken eben zu stimulieren und um die
Kreditvergabe und das
Wirtschaftswachstum anzukurbeln unter
dem ehemaligen EZB-Präsidenten Mario
Draghi erreichte der leitzin 2016 das
Rekord tief von null Prozent und
ermöglichte den nationalen Zentralbanken
über Jahre die Vergabe billiger Kredite
dieses umfassende Maßnahmenpaket wird
Synergien in Gang setzen mit dem Ziel
die Kreditvergabe zu stimulieren und den
wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung des
eurowirtschaftsraumes zu stärken dieser
niedrige Leitzins hat dann in der Folge
zwar einerseits dazu geführt dass die
Wirtschaftskrise überwunden werden
konnte andererseits aber hat der
schleichend das angelegte Geld der
Bürger und Bürgerinnen entwertet denn
auf der Bank gab es keine Zinsen mehr
die Preise aber stiegen dennoch weiter
wenn auch moderat dass diese Politik ja
dazu führt dass Kleinsparer enteignet
werden ja dann tut man sich schon dass
es so wenig gibt ja lohnt sich nicht
mehr auf keinen Fall am besten man legt
und das und das Kopfkissen dann hat man
auch ins Meer davon noch im April
vergangenen Jahres hielt ezb-präsidentin
Kristin Lagarde die Inflation für ein
vorübergehendes Problem ein Zögern dass
ihr massive Kritik eingebracht hat es
fällt mir schwer zu erklären warum die
EZB zögert ich denke sie hat sich geirrt
was die Inflation betrifft und das
Problem ist dass sie die Inflation viel
zu lange ignoriert hat und jetzt ist das
Kind in den Brunnen gefallen als Folge
der Nullzinspolitik stieg die Geldmenge
auf dem europäischen Finanzmarkt wäre
sie konstant geblieben hätten die
aktuell steigenden Energiepreise
gleichzeitig zu sinkenden Preisen an
anderer Stelle geführt die EZB hat das
fehlende Geld aber nachgefüllt und mit
dieser Geldschwemme der aktuellen
Inflation die Basis bereitet die Folge
jetzt steigen die Preise überall wo
spüren Sie die Auswirkungen der
Inflation am stärksten schicken Sie uns
Ihre Hinweise über die heftigsten
Preissteigerung kommen wir nun zu den
Lösungsvorschlägen die Geldmenge und
damit auch die Preissteigerung kann vor
allem die Europäische Zentralbank
beeinflussen
wir beabsichtigen bei unserer Sitzungen
im Juli den Leitzins um 0,25
Prozentpunkte anzuheben schon kurz
danach aber korrigierte die EZB Schritt
unerwartet nach oben auf 0,5%.
ja ich zB Rat gelangte zu der
Einschätzung dass im Zuge seiner
Leitzins Normalisierung ein größerer
erster Schritt angemessen ist als auch
seiner letzten Sitzung signalisiert es
war die erste Leitzinserhöhung der EZB
seit elf Jahren und gleichzeitig der
Schritt in ein Dilemma auf der einen
Seite muss sie die Inflation bekämpfen
indem sie die Zinsen erhöht und auf der
anderen Seite könnten dadurch Länder wie
Italien in Schieflage geraten die EZB
steht vor der Herausforderung einer
gesamteuropäischen Lösung während der
Ölkrise Anfang der 70er Jahre gab es den
Euro noch nicht und die Bundesbank
konnte allein über Zinserhöhungen
entscheiden heute könnte eine weitere
Erhöhung des Leitzinses den Bankrott
höher verschulter starten im Süden der
Eurozone bedeuten der geldpolitische
Handlungsspielraum der deutschen Politik
ist also begrenzt was sie aber tun kann
ist die sozialen Folgen der Inflation
abzufedern und wir sind fest
entschlossen niemanden alleine zu lassen
und das gilt für alle Bürgerinnen und
Bürger des Landes aber es gilt auch für
die Bäckereien in Deutschland und nicht
wirklich überraschend in der Ampel gibt
es da durchaus unterschiedliche
Lösungsansätze
SPD und Grüne wollen reiche an den
Kosten beteiligen und fordern eine
übergewinnsteuer für Konzerne die von
der Energiekrise besonders profitiert
haben es ist nicht gerecht und nicht
vermittelbar dass viele Menschen jetzt
leiden unter der krassen Inflation und
sich einige Konzerne die Taschen
vollschlagen und dann muss ich dann auch
die FDP bewegen bei dem Steuerrecht
haben wir klare Regeln es gibt da
Gewinne und es gibt keine über- oder
untergewinne erste ist dass wir die
zufallsgewinne die jetzt auf dem
Strommarkt erzielt werden abschöpfen
sogenannte übergewinne von Unternehmen
ab einer bestimmten erlösgrenze zu
besteuern hatte die FDP immer abgelehnt
doch nun ist die Rede von
zufallsgewinnen die nicht besteuert
sondern abgeschöpft werden sollen und
der Finanzminister verteidigt das es ist
keine Steuer und es ist auch nicht für
allgemeine Zwecke einsetzbar sondern es
wird eine erlösbremse geschaffen und das
Geld wird eingesetzt um ein Grundbedarf
an Strom für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und eine Entlastung für die Betriebe zu
organisieren die beiden bisherigen
entlastungspakete inklusive Tankrabatt
und 9 Euro Ticket hatten zumindest
vorübergehend ein leicht dämpfenden
Effekt auf die Inflationsrate doch
wuchtige entlastungspakete erfordern
anscheinend lange Sitzungen nach 22
Stunden gab es dann die Einigung auf das
65 Milliarden schwere Paket und dies sei
größer als die ersten beiden zusammen es
geht um 95 Milliarden Euro wenn man die
beiden ersten entlastungspakete
mit einbezieht das ist sehr viel was wir
bewegen es ist notwendig und es soll
dazu beitragen dass die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger durch diese Situation mit uns
gemeinsam durchgehen können und das muss
man in aller Deutlichkeit sagen auch wir
als Verbraucher sind Teil der Lösung
nichts treibt die Inflation so an wie
die steigenden Energiepreise und jeder
von uns hat Einfluss auf den eigenen
Verbrauch was eine Notenbank nicht
kontrollieren kann kann sie ja nicht
bekämpfen insofern wenn Sie jetzt die
Zinsen erhöhen würde würde sie ja nur
das um das Risiko einer Rezession noch
tun obwohl sie den eigentlichen
Preiseffekt die politischen Preise auf
den Weltmärkten für Energie nicht ändern
kann da müssen unsere
Verbrauchsgewohnheiten ändern
grundsätzlich kann die aktuelle
Situation immer noch schwieriger werden
niemand weiß wie sich Pandemie und Krieg
entwickeln werden auch woher Deutschland
in Zukunft seine Energien bezieht bisher
nicht sichergestellt
Wirtschaftsexperten und Expertinnen sind
zwar für das Jahr 2023 mit einem
deutlichen Rückgang der Preiserhöhung
und einer geringeren Inflationsrate aber
die ist mit geschätzten 4,5% immer noch
hoch genug und da sind sich alle
Experten einig die Inflationen wird
erstmal bleiben wenn sie weiterhin bei
aktuellen Tagesgeschehen auf dem
Laufenden bleiben wollen dann abonnieren
Sie gerne diesen Kanal wenn Sie noch
mehr über Inflationen erfahren wollen
dann schauen Sie bei meinem Kollegen von
Mister Wissen to go vorbei eine ganze
Kontext Folge zur Politik in der
corona-pandemie mit meiner Kollegin
aminata belli finden Sie hier